now to our top story and a police
officer accused of the kidnapping murder
of sarah everard has appeared in court
via video link
this morning wolf skies home affairs
correspondent mark white joins me now
from outside to the old bailey mark what
have we learned
well a provisional trial date has been
set for the 25th of october
pc wayne cousins serving metropolitan
armed police officer with the
parliamentary and diplomatic
protection command appeared via a video
link from
prison now he was wearing a wine colored
top and gray
tracksuit bottoms and a scar was visible
on his forehead and over his
left eye now the independent office for
police complaints
commission is investigating how he
received those car
scars in two separate incidents in his
police cell
last week today he spoke only to confirm
his name and address members of sarah
everard's
family also joined the hearing
via video link as well as said that many
other
members of the press and interested
parties because of those
covered 19 social distancing regulations
here
at the old bailey now the prosecution
said that this trial was expected to
last
some four weeks there was a significant
amount of evidence
the prosecutor said that has been
amassed already
pc cousins was remanded back into
custody there was no
application for bail he will appear back
here at
the old bailey on the 9th
of july for a plea and case management
hearing